hupkonzert und autokorso für joe biden
anlass der jährliche protestmarsch für
frauenrechte in den usa
doch wegen der korona lage im us
bundesstaat florida führen die anhänger
in diesem jahr nicht passieren sondern
müssen fahren ihre aussage ist klar es
kann keine weiteren vier jahre mit
donald trump geben die usa brauchen
einen wechsel und zwar hin zu joe biden
warum seid ihr heute hier wir
unterstützen beiden hunden weil er die
richtige wahl für dieses landes was
halten sie von donald trump ich bin sehr
froh heute keine soldaten mehr zu sein
und dass er nicht mein oberbefehlshaber
ist und er respektiert amerika nicht
frauen unterstützen sie beiden ich
glaube er wäre der bessere präsident als
der in der jetzt haben noch ein kurzes
gruppenfoto mit abstand natürlich dann
geht es weiter in die nächste stadt noch
bleiben in gut zwei wochen um für ihren
kandidaten zu werben und sie haben
meinen kollegen maximilian kiewel gerade
im beitrag gesehen jetzt sprechen wir
noch mal live miteinander
max was ist denn das besondere an dieser
region was macht es dort so spannend
berlin das hier das ist ein absoluter
battleground state was bedeutet das dass
hier in florida eigentlich genauso viele
menschen präsident trump unterstützen
wie auch joe biden und diese
zerrissenheit die zeigt sich auch hier
in jacksonville der flächenmäßig größten
stadt der usa wo am dritten november ja
ganze straßenzüge wahrscheinlich nur für
donald trump und dann wieder andere
bezirke nur für joe biden abstimmen
werden also ein super spannende region
welche auswirkungen wird das haben auf
den wahlkampf
ja wir haben es gerade er schon im
beitrag gesehen dass hier ist wahlkampf
extrem dabei dieser autokorso wir haben
gesehen dass am strand wahlkampf
stattfindet dass sich dort unterstützer
versammeln und heute sollen dann hier
die trump flotte in den ort jacksonville
fahren
draußen auf dem meer versammeln sich
gerade hunderte boote voll mit fahnen
für ihren präsidenten wollen dann hier
in den ort reinfahren und das werden wir
euch dann morgen hierbei bild live
zeigen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren